how about we get back to um i guess a
little bit more silliness oh yeah
cool so you know i used to talk about
stories like this on more of my my
secondary channel
but uh it's been we've been inundated
with so much news about chaos and
calamity i figured
the get woke go broke stuff would
probably be more fun to have just like a
chill
hangout conversation and kind of make
fun of this stuff but for those that
haven't
didn't see the story this came out from
bounding into comics august 14th
dc comics publisher jim lee reveals 25
of companies publishing line wasn't
breaking even commits to diversity
and inclusivity amazing they've decided
that
they weren't working so they would just
roast it
varnish it to the ground bounding in the
comic says dc comics publisher and chief
creative officer jim lee recently
discussed the recent layoffs at the
company
and the future of dc comics speaking
with the holly reporter lee stated
this week has been a really heavy
difficult time not just for me
but for the entire organization we've
said goodbye to people that have been
huge contributors
and who have helped define and make dc
what it is today he stated
and they got a bunch of comic pictures
he would he would specifically be asked
if dc comics is still publishing comics
lee answered absolutely 100 it is still
the cornerstone of everything that we do
the need for storytelling updating
mythology it is vital to what we do
he then added the organization leans on
us to share and establish the meaningful
elements of the content
that they need to use and incorporate on
all of their adaptations
we think that about about reaching
global audiences and we see comics as
helping drive
that awareness and that international
brand is very much a part of our future
then lee shockingly revealed just how
bad their lineup had been performing
he also detailed they would be reducing
the lineup significantly
lee stated that said we will be reducing
the size of the slate
but it's about looking at everything and
looking at the bottom 20
25 of the line that wasn't breaking even
or losing money
lee would try and put an optimistic spin
on the dismal state of the lineup
it's about more punch for the pound so
to speak and increasing margins of the
books that we are doing i think we're
starting to see something really
interesting here
especially when it gets into so this is
me i'm not reading anymore
the diversity and inclusivity
specifically they're losing money
but i don't see the get i don't think
this is a get
go broke i think this is a get broke go
woke
yeah it's kind of backwards it's
backwards right i think it could be
basically you know different initiatives
in other areas blah blah let me let me
get straight to the part where he talks
about diversity and inclusivity
he says he then noted they plan to align
the comics with franchise brand content
it's unclear what this means and lee
doesn't really explain it he states it
was about aligning the books to the
franchise brand
we've developed and making sure that
every book we put out we put out for a
reason
when asked about promoting uh marie
javins and michelle wells
to interim editors and chiefs lee
committed the company to
diversity and inclusivity he told the
hollywood reporter
we thought it would be great pairing a
great pairing to bring them together
to help draft and organize the content
we're doing along these lines
across digital across global we want to
make sure we have diversity and
inclusivity
and making it in a way that we have
authenticity to the storytelling that
we're doing
it's really about consolidating all of
our efforts and having
every editors involved in all these
directives and also organizing
broadly speaking in content that is for
kids 6 to 11
and then 12 to 45 it's about
consolidating format and oversight to a
smaller more concentrated editorial
group he elaborated okay i don't care
about the nitty-gritty
for the most part of like the comics you
know their their their business function
but have you have you seen stories like
the
go broke kind of stuff yeah of course
this this to me i think
one thing often gets overlooked these
companies are already failing
i think they're trying to get woke in a
desperate attempt to
sell more comics like you know
you've got a bunch of a specific group
of people who are reading your comics
they then start thinking if we're only
getting young men
how do we get young women of color
diversity and inclusivity then they do
this big launch
it doesn't work then they lose all their
money you know
yeah i mean the idea that by
narrowing the types i mean it's it's
broadening the type of content but it's
also
narrowing it a lot i mean like when
when crap so crowder got remonetized
which was interesting
but i mean the idea that there aren't
conservative
brand there aren't advertisers who want
to advertise on
conservative content right it's just
ridiculous i mean so there's actually
more money for being
open to more content yeah more
controversial content
there like you're just you're limiting
your
your company's revenue if you limit the
amount of content that it's going to run
over
i don't think they see it though i think
they're sitting there saying
we have a dwindling you know sales in
this one demographic
we need to reach another demographic i
remember you know i worked uh
when i worked for fusion i remember
talking to them and i asked them because
of the content they were producing
is are the most the people that watch
and and read these articles are they
women
and the marketing guy said no it's
evenly split and i was like evenly split
among
what 10 people yeah there was like
nobody watching
and so you have these companies that are
like
in order to reach more people we need
diversity and then what ends up
happening is
they do reach an equal number of people
of all different types
substantially less all of a sudden now
they're getting no clicks they're
getting no traffic
and you know it's just artificial it's
like
inclusion for the sake inclusion is good
but inclusion for the sake of inclusion
is just you know it's like seeing a a
cheesy commercial with like one person
from you can tell that it's contrived
they're all like that no one
is drawn to that because that's not
authentic isn't it weird
it's funny because there's like there
are these i don't know what you call
them far right i guess
i don't know if that's the right way to
explain who these people are but there
are conspiracy theorists who think that
these commercials
that have like mixed-race families and
stuff are conspiracies
to you know i don't know spread some
agenda right that's
but it's it's it's literally like corn
pops saying
we want latino families black families
and white families to all buy corn pops
i'm not saying corn pops did this i'm
just you know referencing a random brand
so random brand you know you'll see a
commercial and it'll be a family of like
four different ethnicities yeah and then
also you get these conspiracy theories
online that they're
trying to get woke yeah they're trying
to sell their product to everybody
and it's not culturally culturally
relevant to everybody
it would probably be more effective to
just run four different commercials
with so it's not so obvious and in your
face
yeah because i mean i can see that
i think that you know like jordan
peele's stance
on you know how he's casting his movies
have you have you read about that much
what he doesn't want white men right
yeah he just you know he's making
a deliberate effort to to do that
but he's not con
the casting isn't contrived like okay
he's doing that
he should be able to do that he can do
whatever he wants and he makes good
movies
it's not one person of every race
in just a shallow way you know i haven't
seen any of his movies you haven't
actually maybe i've seen one um
get out nope didn't see it no no no it's
uh i heard it was okay it's good the
reason i didn't see it i didn't see that
other one
i can't remember is because i told it
was preaching
i told that i was like look man i mean
no disrespect to jordan peel right
he's a funny guy but i saw birds of prey
and it scarred me well to be fair you
also got a similar warning about
knives out which you then end up really
liking that's true
yeah so key and peel is pure genius i
loved
keys oh of course yeah absolutely one of
the one of the best segments they did
was when they're like you know uh
he uh is is playing this like very
flamboyant gay guy
and jordan is playing this like normal
guy who keeps asking please tone it down
and he keeps getting called the
homophobe and then it ends with him
saying
this is you know my boyfriend or
whatever and then
you know key's character realizes he's
not a homophobe he's just being kind of
a
you know what i mean that was like one
of the best segments because it made a
point about
you know what does it really mean for
someone to be gay what are they supposed
to act what are the stereotypes
it was hilarious it broke down the
stereotypes while pointing out that
yeah man a lot of these people who claim
to be anti-racist or whatever are
actually just
mean bad people who do violent things
yeah and
they play other characters other
orientations all the time like they
don't go so far to say
oh you have to be you know gay to play a
gay person you have to be
oh we're there man you know yeah but key
appeal don't buy into that i don't think
that they
they understand i think to a degree that
acting is acting and it's actually
incredible to watch somebody who is not
mentally to play that character like
rain man is necessary we need that movie
yeah but the the issue i see with uh
with jordan peele is that he straight up
says
i'm not gonna cast white dudes well i'm
i'm like dude i get it if you
if you know look i get i i really do we
had all the marvel movies the first
thing that come out it's like white dude
why do white dude
and now they're like we want to do
movies that can speak to other
you know audiences or whatever i get it
i do i think the issue is when it's
like fake like you were saying it's
forced because i i'll preach
you know to no end how awesome
spider-man to the spider-verse is i love
that sh i love that movie
it's a great movie and it's diverse it
doesn't need to be a thing
that's why it's like when when peel
comes out and he says it i'm just like i
don't know man
because i often see these movies that
try to do it
are really bad movies like ghostbusters
and birds of prey just
off the top of my head those ones i can
name and i've seen other movies
where they're like we're gonna be
diverse and then it's like you've
sacrificed too much of your budget
towards ideology
instead of a good movie yeah and in that
instance they really bury the lead by
talking about how
diverse and inclusive they want to be
and i think that they've not done enough
market research because if they actually
cared about their market
they would want to be coming up with
interesting stories for example not just
re-running and doing sequels and trying
to build on previous universes
they might actually pause and think what
would make a really great story because
tim can sit down and tell you like eight
different stories off the top of his
head
i'm sure that they have people like that
there who are just as creative and
interesting
they're kind of being stifled i think
they feel like they're kind they're
probably a little bit
handicapped by having to put all of
these barriers on who they can cast for
certain things
i think it's stupid i think it's dumb it
is dumb honestly i think that context
is i think these companies are realizing
they have to detect context
like that's why they re-monetize crowder
i think that they know where he's coming
from and that you can say certain words
in a way that can be understood
to not be offensive and like that's
their biggest challenge
because it's a super difficult problem
with the
ai just running through all the language
pulsing in from audio and
and trying to to detect context and an
intention
because that's you can we we cannot live
in a world where we can't say
certain words in a respectful context
you can't insane you can't
that's what i was saying is the r word
really i i slipped
sorry dude oh yeah isn't that crazy yeah
that's so crazy i mean i don't know
what'll happen you know
yeah but yeah that's the r word now and
that's where we're headed that's where
we're at man
that's how insane everything is getting
like specifically with what they're
doing with these comics with these
movies
soon it's gonna be like people wearing
gray jumpsuits with shaved heads
and they're gonna you know or wearing
hoods you can't see their faces just
just weird everyone will have like a big
box they'll hide in so you can't tell
how tall they are
or you know what they sound like or if
they're a man or woman because as soon
as someone does they get offended
it's not fair there's privilege these
are banning everything already
sir you know we're it's you can't
control what offends people
but what we're seeing with the shutting
down of certain content specifically is
that
it's mass hysteria and because the
initial bias was towards the left
that's the direction it went and and
look man i think it's happened
historically with other other countries
in either direction right left whatever
religious
once the once regular people don't they
they they don't stand up
they're sitting back and all this starts
happening people get scared
to actually push back once that tide
gets reached
and i think the number i was reading is
like 10 once
about 10 of the people have an ideology
it takes over and we're already past
that with the far left
so now coke pepsi right you know all
these big brands the biggest brands the
biggest advertisers have fully embraced
this stuff
the left is pumping out crazy conspiracy
theories like the post boxes are being
stolen
you've seen that it's totally
nonsensical that's where we're at
and you can't you you can barely
challenge any of it
so yeah crowder gets remonetized of
course the left exploded
screaming no he's harassing me around oh
too bad
he won that one straight up he won it
but they took income away from him for a
long time yeah he was out of the partner
program
yeah i mean we got banned from the play
store for like nine months
and then i sent them a link of all of
the porn on twitter and they were like
okay
they banned you for porn no just well
it's like a half naked
image which had a explicit blur over it
wow and then i just emailed them and
they they put it back
so it's just totally arbitrary and
insane that they'll just
destroy businesses like that thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you